hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
application review another HD tutorial
and today I'm going to be taking a look
at destroyed Twitter which is a Twitter
client that I've been using for just
about as long as I can imagine and this
is actually my favorite Twitter client
over tweet deck I actually do prefer
this over tweet deck so I'm going to
showing you this is actually I'm
reviewing it now because this is the
latest version which just came out today
version 2.0 destroyed Twitter 2.0 and it
does have quite a few features that I'll
give you a brief rundown of them not all
of them but I'll go ahead and show you
what I can in the time allotted so
obviously here is your timeline nice and
smooth the same scrollbar and the
pictures and the tweets texts themselves
you can also click on names of the
people to view their profiles and you
can see there's obviously still blue for
mentions one of the things that didn't
transfer over it was themes so there are
no themes themes support yet but you can
still use the default Twitter theme
another thing I want to show you is
preferences this destroyed Twitter has
been known for a very simple interface
you can check out all these preferences
if I just extend this to be a little bit
taller here so they can view all of them
since I'm not going to go through all of
them I'll just show you all of them now
you can have it open up and start up and
always be on top I don't thinking it you
can get rid of the shadow quite yet
but you can choose whether or not they
have small large or no icons which is
cool and you can change your retweet
format I usually use this native one and
one of the cool things is you can change
the sound makes so down here under
notifications for sound you can actually
a preview them per is actually the exact
same sound is TweetDeck if you've ever
heard that but I prefer to leave that
the standard former Amba which just
seems a little bit simpler and I enjoy
it so that's just a brief rundown of a
couple of the preferences and there are
a lot of very cool things now here's the
button down here that you click to tweet
when you click this button you'll have
the same pop-up that you typically get
you can restore your previous tweet
there also what you can do here is
choose to upload a file using this
little plus button for uploading files
and
upload to Twitpic by default and also
for shortening lengths you can auto
shortened URLs and use bitly so instead
of posting a link in a separate box you
can now just put a link in here and
it'll auto shorten so for example
mashable.com hit a space and maybe it's
not a long enough URL but it typically
does shorten the URL
maybe it'll shorten oh when I tweet but
that's a very cool feature and then you
hit submit and you're good to go
but otherwise this has been a quick look
at destroy Twitter you can you can
obviously check it out for yourself I'll
include a link in the description and
you can see if you like this Twitter
client yourself and maybe you'll end up
downloading it and having it as your
default like I do so until next time
thanks for watching this high definition
video tutorial oh another thing I forgot
to mention a complete window resizing so
that's cool anyway this has been mkbhd
thanks for watching this HD tutorial and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace